hi there this is Steve Kaufman founder
of Lync and today I'm going to talk
about the fifth secret to successful
language learning again you'll remember
that so far we've discussed the need to
spend a lot of time enough time now are
they for quite a long period of time the
second secret was to do things that
you'd like to do in the language the
third secret was to develop the ability
to notice what's happening in the
language which all good language
learners have the fourth thing was to
focus on words vocabulary rather than
grammar now the fifth secret is to be
patient patient I see more frustrated
language learners who get upset because
they forget words they get upset because
they don't understand even after
listening many many times through the
same content they certain parts of it
they just don't understand or they watch
a movie many times and they can't
understand it let me tell you that is
absolutely normal and you will have and
continue to have times when you find it
difficult to say what you want to say
and maybe the day before you felt we
were doing very well and all of a sudden
you can't say what you want to say and
that is absolutely normal it's important
to realize that the brain is constantly
learning and there are a number of books
that I've read about how the brain
learns the brain will constantly learn
and it's constantly changing and
renewing itself however it does so on
its own schedule so just because you
studied something doesn't mean you're
going to learn it however you have to be
confident that as you continue and
persevere in your studies and if you're
doing things that you like to do which
in my case is listening and reading and
even if I'm talking to people of course
I'm listening and I'm noticing all of
this is gradually improving my
capability in the language so you have
to accept that and it's not going to be
overnight and it may take six months for
certain
things to sink in but all of a sudden
they do and almost without realizing it
and I've had this feeling all of a
sudden I'll go back to a text that I
struggled with to three months four
months earlier and it seemed that I
never made any progress I could never
understand certain parts of it and all
of a sudden lo and behold it's crystal
clear to me and similarly in speaking
you have these moments of great triumph
when you were in a discussion and lo and
behold you were able to express your
ideas just the way you wanted to or
almost and maybe the next day you won't
be quite so successful but it's a very
gradual process it's not obvious which
words or which you know structures in
the language the brain is going to learn
first or later so you just have to be
patient and you have to believe that
what you're doing is going to lead to
the desired result so anytime you get
frustrated upset because you forgot
something or because you don't
understand something all these negative
thoughts are very damaging to the
learning process again I'm not a
neuroscientist but there is so much of
sort of emotion in in how the brain
learns that it's very important not to
get negative and to be patient and
realize that it's a long road hopefully
an enjoyable road but one that will
definitely lead to fluency in that
language but fluency need not mean
perfection so if you don't expect
perfection but you do expect to
constantly improve then I think you can
afford to be patient so that's my fifth
secret be patient thank you for
listening